[Applaudissements]
ma question ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale dès
votre prise de fonction et il y a encore
quelques jours vous avez prononcé des
mots forts contre le harcèlement votre
position a été courageuse parents
enseignant et victimes tous avaient
besoin d'entendre ce message clair
l'omerta était devenu insupportable les
chiffres publiés hier par l'Ifop pour
l'association Marion la maintendue sont
accablants un jeune sur 5 est victime de
harcèlement scolaire c'était auparavant
1/ 10 et la moitié des victimes n'en
parl pas près de 80 % des parents se
disent inquiets il y a urgence les faits
je le rappelle sont sans précédent avant
le harcèlement scolaire s'arrêtait au
grilles de l'école à 16h30 aujourd'hui
il se répand H24 sur les réseaux sociaux
avec TikTok insta ou snapchat qui par
leur viralité démultiplie les
conséquences dramatiques et ne laisse
aucun répit aux victimes vous avez
monsieur le ministre annoncé 30 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour la création
de brigades anti-harcèlement ces moyens
seront-ils suffisants alors que trop
d'établissements gèent la pénurie
pénurie de médecins scolaires pénurie de
psychologue scolaires pénurie
d'infirmières scolairire pouvez-vous
nous confirmer que tous les personnels
seront désormais systématiquement formés
pour prévenir et détecter allez-vous
rendre obligatoir les questionnaires
d'autoévaluation alors que les 2 heures
banalisées sont facultatives enfin en
matière de sanction pouvez-vous nous
préciser la mise en place des mesures
d'éloignement du harceleur pour protéger
la victime comme notre collègue Marie
Mercier l'avait proposé dans sa PPL
Cigné par 215 sénateurs de tous les bans
de cet hémicycle monsieur le ministre
face à ce drame humain considéraable
l'action doit être à la hauteur de la
communication je vous
remercie